en descendant au niveau de la plaine
maintenant noël c'est toute une série de
décorations à l'intérieur chez vous mais
aussi des villes des villages qui
rivalise d'illumination un merlebach en
lorraine ce sont les habitants eux-mêmes
qui décorent leur maison un noob burel
jean-pierre poste alors voilà ça
pourrait commencer par il était une fois
une fête une passion une maison et voilà
le travail 14 ans que ce jardin
extraordinaire de merlebach en lorraine
attire tous les soirs pendant les fêtes
passant a mis les passants touristes car
de touristes et bien sûr les enfants
je trouve qu'à des gens disent c'est
dingue beaucoup de mal pour faire
souffrir les enfants avec leurs
décorations
je trouve ça excellent hier me rappelle
beaucoup de souvenirs de jeunesse je
crois lorsqu'on voit tout ça c'est très
beau mais le plus incroyable ils ne le
verront jamais car à l'intérieur
gérard et sa famille ont déployé des
trésors d'ingéniosité pour noël
des figurines il y en a tant qu'on ne
peut même plus les compter petit train
père noël animé sapin chantant en veux
tu en voilà chaque année davantage mais
pourquoi
c'est un cadeau du tout d'abord jugé
offensant ma famille parce que c'est si
ça semblait encore pis un joli fait de
noël la même temps il ya beaucoup de
monde qui viendra des puits qui sont
adhérents sur de la maison je leur
montre aussi un peu de joie et de
bonheur avec ses 25 mille lumières
gérard a donné le lie tous les voisins
ont accordé leur maison c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'effet boule de neige
ils se font plaisir d'une part nantes au
départ et ensuite je pense qu'ils se
prennent au jeu puis veulent toujours
faire mieux
chacun y va de son style et son budget
certains se font même sponsorisés c'est
une passion un monde très branché sur
noël